il y a urgence pour les Ukrainiens alors
que l'hiver s'installe dans tout le pays
écoutez les dernières informations de
notre correspondant à Kiev Gulliver
crack
cette fois-ci c'est plutôt au dessin qui
a été la ville la plus affectée par les
frappes d'hier la grande ville portuaire
du Sud qui a été complètement coupé
d'électricité de chauffage et d'eau
courante après les frappes ce matin le
maire de la ville a dit que
l'électricité est rétablie sur la
plupart de la ville pour le chauffage
les grandes centres qui génèrent le
chauffage sont tous ont tous été
rallumés selon le meilleur ce qui fait
que toutes les cliniques et les hôpitaux
de la ville sont maintenant chauffés
mais pour certains quartiers de la ville
pour les résidences des bâtiments
particuliers les immeubles
d'appartements il faut être un petit peu
plus de temps pour rétablir le chauffage
et je pense que c'est un peu la même
chose pour l'eau courante mais à chaque
fois qu'il y a ces frappes les
compagnies d'électricité de chauffage
d'eau
ukrainienne se mettent au travail
extraordinairement vite et et en vrai
moi impressionné le pays est d'après un
expert en énergie que j'ai rencontré il
y a pas longtemps à qui est vraiment la
communauté internationale aussi et assez
impressionnée par leur performances mais
comme ils disent à chaque fois il
commence à manquer de pièces ils ont
besoin de plus de pièces pour faciliter
les réparations et on voit très bien que
tous les systèmes est très très tendu
sous une très grande pression puisque en
réalité les frères d'hier du point de
vue des Russes ont été un peu un échec
puisque l'écrasante majorité des
requêtes a été écrasé assez peu
relativement peu de cible
infrastructures importantes ont été
touchées mais tout de même même quelques
frappes peuvent vraiment causer des
problèmes à travers tout le pays ce
n'est pas uniquement les régions qui ont
été frappées qui sont affectées
maintenant par ces coupures de courant
de courant et de chauffage il y a des
endroits à travers
tout le pays qui sont affectés
Gulliver Craig